in many ways it would seem that western
europe along with canada and probably
australia are seated farther up on the
crazy train and you know that's probably
true but the important point is that
we're all on the same train headed over
the same precipice and down into the
same dark
depths uh to appear then over our
northern border or across the ocean it's
to look at our immediate future it's
like looking into a crystal ball
and that's why this story which hasn't
gotten very much attention in this
country ought to uh ought to get some
attention not to give us pause today's
world is uh pretty scary at least it can
be too many people don't seem to care
about the truth about moral standards
all that is flown out the window and i'd
argue that it that all of that is rooted
in people becoming less religious that's
why it's more important than ever that
we take a step back from all this
craziness and keep our relationship with
god strong and intact the best way to do
that is by praying every day with hallo
hallow is the number one christian
prayer app in the u.s it's like calm or
head space but it's rooted in catholic
faith as opposed to the religion of
leftism hallow offers over 5000 audio
guided prayers meditations
and christian music tracks some of the
most popular prayers include the daily
rosary the gospel reading the daily
psalm with bishop baron
also the bible in a year with father
mike schmitz and there's uh prayers by
some names and voices you might
recognize like mark wahlberg mario lopez
jim caviezel they've got minute
meditations they've got meditations for
sleep they've got really importantly kid
prayer and meditation as well halo helps
me find my peace and calm throughout the
day helps me sleep better lower my
anxiety levels and teach my kids not to
be terrible humans on top of it so let
hello become
your source of peace and strength and
strengthen your faith today go to
hallow.com
matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684 and get an extended
three-month free trial during which
you'll have access to all 5 000 plus
meditations and pairs that's hello.com
matt walsh or text pray 21855
for three months free reclaim your peace
in this crazy world download hallo today
the daily mail reported this week
they report an army veteran was arrested
by police for
causing anxiety after retweeting a
picture of a swastika made out of pride
flags on social media darren brady 51
has slammed hampshire police for
impeding his right to free speech after
he's placed in handcuffs on friday at
his home in aldershot for sharing a meme
footage of the arrest was widely shared
on social media and showed an officer
who told mr brady he was being he was
being apprehended because his post had
caused anxiety and been reported to
authorities the image mr brady retweeted
was of a swastika that had been
digitally manipulated and was made out
of four lgbt pride flags
well clearly the best way to disprove
the point he was making with the
swastika meme is to arrest him for
posting it
certainly not as it's not as though such
a response exactly demonstrates the very
thing the meme was commenting on
but i think you need to hear you heard
the reason there about anxiety but you
need to hear it for yourself the british
police officer um explaining this as
he's making the arrest so here's the
footage now watch
which hampshire police would
realize how ridiculous this is it is
traditionally it is thought to come to
this
what did what did it need to come to you
to this level because i don't understand
i posted something that he posted you
come to arrest me you don't arrest him
why has he come to this why am i in
cuffs because there's something
he shared then i shared because someone
has been caused obviously anxiety
based upon
someone has been caused anxiety by your
social media post you're in handcuffs
and will be carted to jail because your
meme
made somebody anxious my favorite thing
is the tone the officer uses he says
obviously someone has been caused
anxiety it's obvious of course he's
going to arrest you for creating anxiety
in the precious fragile mind of some
gender non-conforming person obviously
what else is he gonna do
what to the sane among us seems utterly
insane and totally beyond the bounds of
reason is to him
self-evident and uncontroversial
well this is no surprise coming from a
british british police officer after all
these are the people just recently a few
weeks ago caught on film in uniform
dancing at a gay pride rally let's see
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's some uh real police work there
now i suppose we have no room to laugh
over here in the states we've seen cops
in this country kneel at you know in
submission at blm rally so basically the
same sort of thing and we especially
cannot laugh because we are fast
approaching the day when
a meme critical of the trans agenda will
result in more than just a twitter
suspension
soon we're going to see people getting
carted away in handcuffs too
and it will happen it's going to happen
and soon and that move will begin
if biden has anything to say about it on
college campuses with this
administration's proposed changes to
title ix like we talked about when the
proposal was first published a little
while ago biden
wants to change title ix
not only to give men the unquestioned
right to access any female facility or
sports team anywhere they want without
impediment but also to make it a legal
violation as the british police officer
says to cause anxiety to a protected
class of people
there was a lawyer named cece o'leary
who recently explained the changes at a
heritage foundation event and she
explained that
under the current title ix guidelines
a
student or staff member at a university
could be considered in violation if they
engage in harassment
a verbal harassment that is severe
pervasive and objectively offensive
that's the current rule as it is as it
stands now there are obviously problems
even with the rule as it stands
potential problems but it does create a
relatively high bar
okay if you want to get someone kicked
off campus for harassing you you have to
prove that what they're saying was
offensive
uh and and pervasive and severe all
three of those things
which means that you can't
hear something that somebody says that
offends you one time and then get the
person kicked out of school
you have to prove that you were harassed
in a way that was severe and pervasive
and personal towards you
but as o'leary explains biden wants to
change the end
to an ore
so it's not severe and pervasive it's
severe or pervasive
and that will have absolutely
devastating effects for free speech on
campus obviously by design let's listen
to her explain it speech that would be
severe pervasive and objectively
offensive
would be
a a man calling a woman a derogatory
name
he says it and we all agree that it's a
it's a bad name he says it over and over
again
and it causes her to maybe fear for her
physical safety maybe he's shouting it
at her as he's running after her that
would be harassment or maybe he's saying
it over and over and over again in class
to the point where she does not feel
safe going to class anymore that would
be harassment under the current rule
under the proposed change to the rule it
would just be saying a comment about um
it would be misgendering somebody it
would be saying
the wrong pronoun that that person does
not identify with under the new rule
that person could find that comment
severe period and they could report you
and
the college could find you
guilty of harassment
so under this new proposed change to
title ix we are worried that students
are going to have their speech chilled
even more than it already is students
are going to be deterred from ever
speaking up and saying anything because
they risk especially conservative
students will risk their views
being targeted and being punished now on
their campus so
you know a concrete example of this
could be you want to host a conservative
speaker let's say you want to have matt
walsh come on to campus and debate
somebody under these new changes to
title ix you might not be able to do
that because matt walsh could be labeled
a harassing figure and this is harassing
speech and therefore the college will
not allow him to come onto campus
so there are definitely some serious
concerns here with this title ix um
change and and i know there are other
concerns as well that i'm sure my
co-panelists can speak to
well of course you want to keep that
unsafe character off your campus but
generally
the groundwork is already laid here the
foundation has long since been excavated
now all the tyrants have to do is start
building on the work they've already
done
to say something that somebody in a
privileged class doesn't like to make
them uncomfortable whether intentionally
or not is to commit harassment
and harassment is a violation on college
campuses harassment is a crime actually
criminals get arrested so you see how
the dots connect it's not very hard to
see but in fact the foundations for this
kind of words our violence idea uh
foundation goes further back and is
deeper than most people realize
if you have uh heeded my many
recommendations to read carl truman's
book the rise and triumph of the modern
self then you'll know that
this is all the consequence
of um what other philosophers have done
dubbed living in the age of the
psychological man or the expressive
individual
now for most of human history as truman
talks about in this book human beings
found meaning and purpose through
external
realities um happiness and fulfillment
could be found in the ways that we are
situated within stable structures like
the family the community the church
your country right individuals define
themselves by these relationships and
these roles if you had gone to a person
you know at any point before modern
times and asked them to tell you about
themselves they would have immediately
started talking about
the roles that they that they play they
would have identified that i'm a father
i do this for a living that's how they
would have um identified themselves they
probably would have
listing their faith probably first and
foremost
but that's all changed
in the modern age
now individuals are encouraged to find
meaning inside themselves as truman
wrote in an essay on this subject a
couple years ago
it is the this is the notion that human
flourishing is found primarily in an
inner sense of well-being that
authenticity is found by being able to
act outwardly as one feels inwardly and
that who we are is largely a matter of
personal choice not external imposition
and of course i would add that the
rejection of external imposition
includes
biology and nature
because we're now meant to believe that
even nature even god cannot impose on us
any definition of our true selves
nobody decides who or what we are nobody
in nothing it's totally up to us this is
entirely determined by our own egos and
our ego is where we live
we are absorbed within it barely coming
up for air
this shift in the way that human beings
see themselves
this transformation or degradation
as the case may be in the very
definition of selfhood
is what explains nearly everything that
we're seeing happen around us
and it's what has led
and will continue to lead to the
forcible suppression of many kinds of
speech
especially speech that causes someone to
question their inner experience of their
own selfhood right speech that causes as
the police officer said anxiety
since your inner self is all that
matters since it's the truest version of
yourself then speech which interferes
with it becomes a form of violence it's
it's murder in effect
and that's why the enemies of free
speech can stamp out free speech
wherever they find it
while claiming
and actually believing
that they cherish free speech they could
be on this crusade to utterly destroy
free speech while telling themselves and
everybody else
and and being deluded enough to actually
believe that that they cherish the very
thing that they're destroying
because in their minds what they're
attacking is in speech you know it's
violence it's assault
it's murder
maybe not physically
but internally
and as we've seen the internal
is all that
matters and that's what's happening well
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
to get more content like it if you're
craving more content go watch or listen
to my full show at dailywire.com spotify
or wherever you get your podcast